je lui parle tous les jours on prend des
nouvelles de nos amis de la télé réalité
et on va débuter avec du gros niveau
puisqu'on va commencer que les
marseillais alors je rappelle l'idée de
l'émission vous allez à marseille vous
cherchez des jeunes qui n'ont pas de
travail voulais filmer à rien faire et
c'est à dire des stars sur w9 alors j'ai
une très mauvaise nouvelle
le torchon brûle entre laura aikin si
vous ne savez pas qui sont ces deux
personnes mais le torchon brûle ça fait
plusieurs jours qu'on sentait la tension
monte entre les deux et là ça allait
beaucoup beaucoup trop loin puisque la
seule solution pour laura c'est prendre
une décision terribles et irréversibles
laura va-t-elle quitter l aventure laura
va-t-elle demander le départ de kevin
laura va-t-elle prendre une décision qui
va changer sa vie
lauranne on peut plus kevin elle doit
prendre une décision et regarder la
vérité sur cette décision est bien plus
tragique
attention âmes sensibles femme alors tu
as raison comme ça allait forza taper
très fort entre kevin et mans voilà je
pense que là on va arrêter
[Musique]
on va arrêter les barbecues
je prends la décision elle va arrêter
c'est anthony et on félicite kevin et
carla qui vient d'avoir un petit bébé
une petite fille qu isabelle ruby et
d'ailleurs on critique souvent cette
émission que finalement on se rend
compte qu'il ya quand même des vrais
couples qui se rencontrent parce qu'ils
sont tous en train de faire des bébés je
suis sympa je sais pas il ya de l'amour
dans bas bien sûr il ya qu'ici qui a pas
de bébé sur les secrets
dépêchez-vous parce que d'ailleurs
d'avoir bientôt un repas sans transition
sur l'île de la bataille des couples et
oui ça fait plusieurs jours que les deux
épreuves du jeu se complique pour nos
candidats
il ya quelques jours ils ont dû lancer
des boules de pétanque hier ils ont
grimpé à des poteaux c'est un crescendo
mais la tonsure l'heure est grave dans
la bataille des coupes puisque la
production a décidé de faire passer à
nos candidats
l'épreuve la plus dangereuse au monde
attention 100 % d'échec assuré regardez
[Musique]
personne ne doit vous dicter le sens de
votre fidélité
mais pourtant aujourd'hui quelqu'un va
vous dicter une histoire de fidélité et
dignité
[Musique]
ce mec
[Applaudissements]
mentalités sont roux de leur vie je vais
m'en faire une dictée ici cette
orthographe eric naulleau sûrement oui
jésus est meilleur quand j'étais petit
on apprenait l'orthographe vraiment à la
dure mère et moi coccyx coccyx coq 6
coccyx coccyx co2 c'est y x oued où
maria censure de sa prédécesseure si je
crois que c'est ça on va demander en
régie doit regretter toutes les façons
j'ai un dictionnaire ici beinheim et
épeler moi alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va s'intéresser à dylan dylan il a
deux passions dans la vie les légumes et
donner des conseils de merde mais je le
clip tourne study dan et quand il
mélange les deux mêmes sa copine fidji
bas elle comprend un regard des mails
comme à l'affect
au début la monture elle s'est attachée
à toi très fort il était très fort et du
coup vous êtes dans un conte contre les
deux
mélanie sont part de quelqu'un il a
besoin de ça on le sait tous elle
s'empare d'une croix du coup ça devienne
brûlé c'est un cocon
des manifs saison
on va voter pour la meilleure serait
grand poète en fait ma mais j'adore
alors un vrai amateur même parler de
carla et kevin ya un instant quelle idée
de génie ils ont un bébé bébé ruby et
oui c'est une nouvelle télé réalité qui
vient de débarquer sur six plaies 6 pc
comme netflix mais avec le budget d'idf1
ça s'appelle carla plus kevin égale bébé
ruby donc c'est le spin off des
marseillais w9 qui peut expliquer ce
qu'est un spin off
il est bizarre c'est enfin une série
dérivée d'une autre série heroes
différentes séries spin off de tpm a
contredit pas pour le plaisir
tout est là d'une app alors on suit les
aventures du couple kevin et carla qui
vont devenir parents aux dit bien
évidemment kevin doit être là pour
bichonner la future maman prendre soin
d'elle l'aider à supporter sa grossesse
et bat kevin il est là mais pas doux et
demain dernière et qu on va voir qui
avait rassemblé allez on va se reposer
et la mort
je laisse ton ballon là bas tard ah les
cons on sait pas quoi va ressembler bien
non aujourd'hui sont traités qui tient
sur le groupe est comme ça on sait que
oui c'est bien mais même à l'écho à
l'écho en 3d même ce même si l'écho 3d
c'est un truc absolument formidable et
magique je m'en vois pas qui ressemble
ces voix là on fait une éco en 3d quand
j'étais enceinte et le médecin m'a dit
elle a une très grosse bouche non mais
kastali sont réglés et bat le gardien on
voit pas ses yeux
voilà les sang et or est allé à l'époque
avait déjà donné du tonus alors
l'accouchement est imminent et kevin se
demande quand ça va arriver car c'est
une question de jours
en tout cas car là le planning bien dans
la tête et c'est très précisément le
jour où ça va arriver
regardez
à devenir maman me battre
c'est l'origine
[Applaudissements]
ça leur on est très content pour carla
et qu'emmi mais personne n'est choqué
sur le fait qu'ils instrumentalisent
leurs enfants pribyl a rien demandé de
mettre une star de télé c'est bon ça va
l'être encore à la télé là il n'est pas
né encore oui non mais on va naître il
va être une sorte de personnage de télé
réalité sa compétence aux sciences po
mais ça veut rien dire nabil a décidé de
justement ne pas ne pas le montrer ne
pas l'immortaliser ne pas lui faire de
fait après son scandale c'est un oui
mais lui enfin n'a pas de nom mais l'on
voit les pas du révérend a remporté
l'émission se terminera il aura
peut-être un mois il va pas être
traumatisé bien je suis assez pendant
l'année passée le droit de pas être
émerveillé c'est pas bizarre était de
faire les rabat joie qui a quand même
des candidats elles sont encore
enceintes il ya déjà un instagram de
leur bébé qui a déjà trois semaines et
c'est vrai que là on se veut dire que
c'est un petit peu on se trouve est
instrumentalisé quand même voilà merci
heurtoir tout de suite après en
compétition de patinage
[Rires]
alors
été filmé sans aucune censure dans cette
émission on assiste donc à
l'accouchement de madame et comme on ne
change pas une équipe qui gagne car la
pose des questions assez curieuse au
gynécologue regarder on sent qu au début
le docteur se dit ah bah tiens les
marrante et puis rapidement il dit ouais
c'est cool quand même village
[Musique]
puis à la fois excitée parce que je vais
vivre et à la fois je suis tétanisé
parce que je connais pas cette sensation
prochain
[Musique]
en droit d'être chaud qu'à partir de ce
moment là c'est peut-être mois seulement
mais quand vous êtes choqué la démission
pourquoi tests auxquels il ya rien
gestion comme baby boum et tout ça voilà
c'est simplement chanter un moment
extrêmement intime je suis alors mais il
doit baby boom il le faut et il me
regarde je regarde pas mais eux ont
décidé de le montrer s'ils sont un
événement heureux s'ils ont envie de
partager leur bonheur avec leurs fans
savent a été un coup vous verrez on le
fera avec et on le fera ici